moscovites are being watched closely
200,000 cameras will be installed not
only on public streets but also at the
entrances of private living quarters not
many people are aware that their
biometric data images body measurements
and other characteristics are being
captured real-time and transmitted to
police monitors within moments a
person's identity can be determined and
his place of residence if the person is
on the one at least it means he is a
criminal if you have not committed a
crime you don't have to be worried the
villain will be identified if he is a
caught on camera Russia is taking the
phrase big brother is watching you to a
new level with biometric data collection
seemingly available at nearly every
street corner the authorities say they
can easily catch criminals but critics
say they'll will keep a close eye on
activists opposing the Putin's regime at
the same time police have been accused
of using face recognition technology to
crackdown on peaceful protesters during
a wave of anti-government demonstrations
last summer
Alyona Popova says she was arrested
after taking part in a protest in 2018
she filed a case against the police but
a Moscow Court dismissed it she will
mount a not a legal challenge against a
technology next month it's poisoning by
using facial recognition technology the
state violates people's privacy and I'm
saying they're doing it illegally I'm
convinced that they unlawfully collect
and user biometric all data and they
don't have a right to do so they must
stop but the company that designed the
technology says its system is being used
legally in Russia and activists should
be more worried about their mobile
phones when you're talking about your
phone so your jail position is always on
I know who is that all the content is
monitored which you're saying over the
phone
speech recognition is always on so
unlike telecom provider or whatever so
basically I have like when he went need
from the clock from the government
perspective so this is the number one
thing the company claims it can identify
people even if only their eyes are
visible when we do the test we do find a
loophole the company admits that
mismatches can happen and aims to
improve the system not only the systems
invasiveness and accuracy is being
questioned but also its security
recently Russian media discovered that
captured images are being hacked and
sold on the black market which instead
of combating crime could make a
criminals work a lot easier step fasten
al-jazeera Moscow